[Musique]
nous allons chercher tous les mots
méchants les mots andy comme injure à
des gens qui sont d'une autre race ou
d'un autre pays que le nôtre
alors qu'est ce que vous avez déjà
entendu dire ou 10 vous-même ou entendu
dire autour de vous nourry retournera
ton pays tu es venu en france pour
manger le pain des français
oui je le sais quoi d'autre ou démodés
comme on les traite les parlante les
arabes
sale arabe ou bien ça là j'irai encore
d'autres choses seul chrono
oui ahmed oui pour les chinois à
washington chine bloque les portugais
pourtant ioukos tous les corail ou des
tous ces ados les espagnols c'est pas
moi c'est les italiens rythme là le
titre que moi je les freins de bogies
pack wii
menouar wégleau compagnon vous avez
cherché penser à un copain un copain que
vous connaissez bien qu'ils aient
appartenu sabolien copine tu penses le
sirha nasser ben toi toi que tu penses
nasser les autres renards
alors est ce que quand vous voyez nasser
est ce que vous avez envie de lui dire
retourne dans ton pays basque ansa le
rab trouille s'amuser aussi comment
pourquoi vous n'avez pas envie de lui
dire alors ce que disent les gens
trichent avec nous il nous dit pas tout
ça qui fait peine à cette heure et
président de l'egypte oui pourquoi tes
parents t'ont appelé le crj pas tu
verras jamais demander à ton avis et les
abeilles pourquoi peut-être parce que
c'est un algérien où était-il
intéressant que vous de traiter en
classe le problème du racisme parce que
le problème commençait à devenir assez
vif en particulier entre deux enfants un
petit garçon algérien et un petit
français sont deux enfants qui sont de
même fort ce sont sans doute les enfants
les plus rapides
ceux qui réussissent le mieux dans la
classe et la rivalité la compétition se
manifeste essentiellement par le rejet
du petit algérien par le petit français
qui essaient de faire rejeter l'autre
par toute la classe les enfants avaient
décidé de faire un goûter de noël et que
chacun ferait
des gâteaux ou frais faire passer sa
maman un gâteau et le petit deux petits
garçons algérien avait fait faire des
gâteaux algérien très content d'aller
faire goûter ses camarades
c'est un goût un peu spécial certain
nombre ne pas aimer et n'ont pas trop
réagi jusqu'à ce que le petit le petit
rival de 2,7 enfants à y jeter son
gâteau à la poubelle de lanton devant
tout le monde en disant ce gâteau là
c'est dégoûtant et les autres enfants
qui n'aimait pas le gâteau en question
sont allés aussi jeter langatte au
visiblement à la poubelle et le petit
enfant algérien c'est n'a rien dit il
est allé se mettre dans un coin assez
pâle et s'est mis à pleurer quand il a
vu que que tout le monde partait faire
la poubelle
et ils ont emmené un petit peu rester là
à ce moment là les autres ne se sont
même pas rendu compte de ce que de ce
qu'ils avaient pu beaucoup peiné lors
leurs camarades de futaba complet pour
moi oui on m'a dit que c'était
il était au service militaire oui et
puis il ya une guerre la guerre
d'algérie oui et mon père ya été et il a
fait la guerre contre lille est rien et
puis quand il est revenu il était
raciste contre les algériens pourquoi
parce qu'il la lui fit la guerre et les
algérie avait tué un de ses amis et on
perd il avait tué les algériens beau
fouet et qu'est ce que tu crois que les
algériens pensent la pomme qu'il soit
entre des français mais en tout cas mon
père les racistes contre les algériens
je mets ici je joue avec en entrée ou
d'y croire et tu crois vraiment que les
étrangers gagnent plus que les français
oui pourquoi tu crois ça parce qu'il ya
un ami à mon père qui a kiss payolle et
puis qui vient travailler en france ils
gagnent plus que les autres qui
travaillaient qui feront le même y sont
admis mais qui rend les spas et me
disent non ici en france c'est sûr de ça
qu'est ce qui fait qu métier
[Applaudissements]
cuisinier et gagne plus qu'avec les
français sur la question d'un les rues
moi je trouve que là par exemple parce
qu'il ya certains qui les touchent moins
que les français oui que c'est pas
toujours mon papa le spyware l'école
bref on t'a toujours appeler comme ça
wisches l'école grecque est hors de
l'école non ça fait une différence non
cet égard on appelle des femmes en moi
ça me fait rien moi qu'on me traite de
français parce que c'est mon pays et
puis il lui arrive quand on traite de
sale français au nom commençait tout si
ça te fait quelques chaudes et froides
et ça m'arrive pas souvent je veux dire
nicolas comment ça m'est arrivé comme
traite de sale français et j'ai répondu
je suis pas français c'est tous les
hadjis algériens qui m'avait dit ça je
le méritais une chose avant non non
quand on passe des pitres est de loin
plus aidé du jarret il est déjà dans
l'eau à côté
bon et plus répond quoi je n'étais pas
dans ton pays mais moi j'y suis séparé
de leur vie retourne chez toi
des fois est-ce que tu as le sentiment
que tu leur fais de la peine qu'on te
dise ah ouais tu le fais car même s'il
m'a en fait tu veux pas me laisser
tu nous aider on m'appelait la salle
juive
oui j'ai bien dit ça puis tu nous as dit
aussi ça m'est égal
parce que c'est vrai c'est parce qu'il
est vrai que j'ai aussi fluide mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas vrai que ça
alors ça te fait quelque chose quand on
t'appelle s'adjuge non je m'en fous de
ce que les autres disent puisque je sais
que je sais que c'est pas vrai t'aimes
pas bien quand on parle de racisme
[Musique]